hey guys pete here i've got a new video
for the expanse today but i have to
start things off with a spoiler warning
because i'm going to be talking about
the books
i'll be talking to book readers about
some changes we've seen in season 5
through episode 5 but we'll
ultimately be looking at what that means
as far as where the story is going
so if you haven't read the books past
where we are in the tv series
and you don't want to be spoiled then
this video won't be for you
feel free to check out any of my other
expanse content
where i stay away from spoiling future
events in the series
but as far as this video is concerned
you've been warned and now let's jump
into it
so we're halfway through season five and
unsurprisingly it's doing a pretty good
job of adapting
nemesis games on a personal level i
guess one thing i realized was how
internal a lot of what happens with the
characters is in this book
and what a challenge that presents for
making good tv
for making that come off i mean
obviously i understood that what i liked
about this book was getting to see
point of view chapters from amos naomi
and alex
after only seeing them through the eyes
of other characters up into this point
but i guess i didn't realize
that that is perfect for books but not
so great for tv
so i guess some ground rules for this
discussion based on everything that the
creators have
said i'm expecting that when season six
comes to an end as their run on amazon
ends we're essentially going to end that
just like the end of babylon's ashes
at this point i don't expect them to
move up anything from the romans versus
the goth storyline
i think they'll set up laconia but leave
it open-ended and when the season comes
to a close i'll do another one of these
videos where i really go into
speculation on what season six might
look like so starting from there what
are the things that need to happen
in order for the story to stay in line
with what happened in the books
we needed the crew to split up we needed
amos and naomi
to face their past those things more or
less are progressing on their normal
path
we needed alex and bobby to team up so
that we could get an idea about what was
happening on mars
the seeds of the lakonian empire being
planted there
we needed avasarala to be put in charge
of earth
in the aftermath of the attacks we
needed holden to be isolated somewhat so
that he could grow as a character
and game-wise it has to make sense that
he'll turn down the role of the head of
the transport
union when it's offered to him books one
through four holden probably wouldn't
have done that
earth has to start dying marco needs to
make his case for the free navy
and there needs to be some pushback
against that as far as changes
fred dying early is one of the big ones
it seems surprising to me because
there's this void now
in the regular opa or the moderate wing
whatever you want to refer to them as
how he dies isn't terribly important i
mean it was nice to see someone die in a
high g maneuver just to show that that
is a thing that can happen
story wise it does change things some
the three characters at the center of
the taiko story don't really have the
opa connections that fred did
bull's an unknown he's basically taking
the place a book drummer
and the fact that he's an earther makes
it pretty unlikely he'd step in to take
fred's place
for monica it's the same and i guess you
could imagine a way that holden just
steps into that role
he's well known to belters in the same
way that fred johnson was when he first
came on the scene
but fred had anderson dawes behind him
which brings up the question
what is dawes up to are they still gonna
do fred's funeral
that's so out of whack with the timeline
it's hard to say
personally i'd be pretty surprised if
jared harris showed up to reprise the
role at this point in the story
for one they would have had to keep it a
complete secret there's been no talk of
that whatsoever
and it also seems unlikely because he's
working on the apple plus series for
foundation and work for both series
would have been going on around the same
time
so i'm interested in hearing your
thoughts on what happens in fred's
absence
the other idea i hear a lot is that
drummer is going to come and take his
place but that
all hinges on how much of michiopaw's
role she's taking on this season
based just off of what we've seen in
season five it looks like she's just
michio paw
she'll join the free navy and then
she'll follow marco until she doesn't
one of the things that makes that seem a
little less likely is
michio's motivations in the book
compared to where drummer's at
they both kind of went independent for
the same reasons
but they gave drummer this close
relationship with ashford
joe ashford is obviously a much more
likable character
and she did have a connection with him
and even though she had a falling out
with fred
she still respects him michio didn't
like either of them so i could kind of
see it going both ways i could kind of
see her looking at things pragmatically
and then joining the free navy because
it makes the most sense for her family
but with things how they are the fact
that marco killed two people that she
cares about i could also see a split in
her faction
because at this point at least it seems
that some of them are sympathetic to
what the free navy are trying to do
and none of them at this point seem to
have the same connection with fred
johnson
or ashford overall i do think by the end
of season six she will be in michio's
role
as far as becoming the leader of the
transport union
this will change book drummers the
original drummer's
importance later on but i think that
carragee is such a fan favorite and this
character has become such a big part of
what's going on in the belt i think it
makes for a more satisfying ending
to have her be there for that it could
just be an easter egg but i find it a
little bit interesting that they named
one of her wives michio
and that does make me think that maybe
there will be a split
but at the same time i can't see them
building up that character
who so far isn't really even the most
important of the people on her
ship to have this really exciting pirate
queen
redemption arc kind of thing that michio
does
but i'm interested to hear what you guys
are thinking about that
as far as other changes i think most of
what we've seen in naomi's story are
just details
they change the details around how she
got to the pella
how she contacted holden about the rossi
i think mostly it's still going in the
same direction
i think most of those are just changes
out of necessity they're not able to
show us what she's thinking we don't get
that great insight to how she figures
out her plan
as her time on the pella passes i think
philip will try to bring her over to
marco's
side sin is already doing that he'll
continue to do that but i think for the
whole thing to work at the end
her setting it up so that the free navy
go dutchman
i think for that to have the weight that
it does she has to believe that philip
might
be on the ship at that time so i don't
see any major changes in his story
and i don't think any of the changes
we've seen in season 5 so far
hinted any major changes in naomi's
story speaking of going dutchmen
i get a lot of questions about the high
council and the fact that they use
soviet terror as the contact point
rather than
duarte himself during alex and bobby's
investigation
i think as far as sovietteres concerned
i don't think he's a replacement for
duarte
i think his ending will be exactly the
same i think that we'll see him go
dutchman
i think maybe they just introduced him
early so we know who he is when we see
that happen
if you remember reading the book the
first time in the epilogue he's someone
we just
meet right then for admiral duarte a lot
of people have pointed out it doesn't
really make sense to cast someone
in that role for just one interaction
with alex
i'm not sure how much we'll hear about
him in this season but we need to hear
about him in season six
you can't really do that story without
the martians breaking away and going
through the laconia gate
i think if you think about the way that
they ended season three when they
thought that was the end of the series
the ring gates opened and that was
something to think about but not
something you got answers to and i think
that laconia will be about the same
we'll see the end of the free navy we'll
see the formation of the transport union
and we'll know that there's something
going on out there that might threaten
it all
in the future so i don't think they're
editing duarte
or laconia from the story but i don't
think we'll see much of him
maybe none of him or much more of what's
going on with that
unless they find a way to adapt the
final trilogy
beyond those points i don't see any
major deviations
in the moment it seemed a little
surprising that marco threatened the
inner planets with the proto-molecule
nobody knew that it was even stolen in
the books so i was wondering if they
were changing something there
but one of the questions i get most from
show only people lately is
how is marco paying for all this and of
course that's the only thing that really
makes sense
he has cortazar he has the
proto-molecule he's trading that to
duarte
maybe through soviet terror and they're
using his attack as a distraction so
that they can
hightail it out of the system there's
been a lot of discussion about whether
they
have changed how much destruction is
going to happen on earth
and honestly i think they're just being
very slow about revealing it
when you read the book the first time
you could just keep going you kept
getting more of an idea about it but it
was in the background and it wasn't
crazy at first
with the week-long breaks in between the
episodes we haven't seen much time
pass in the show yet so no one really
understands how bad it's gonna be
that said i think it has to be as bad
the only way i could even see it being
different is like they made it so that
marco was trying not to destroy earth
and that backfires
when the cascade does happen where the
systems start to fail
that's a little bit out there and i
don't really know why they would do that
but i think the end result has to be the
same
in the books about 50 percent of the
earth's population died
and in my opinion even if it's not
exactly that it needs to feel like that
bottom line things can never be the same
beyond not being able to say confidently
what i think they're gonna do as far as
replacing fred
and what they're doing with drummer i
guess the other situation where i don't
really know where they're going
is with alex and bobby by removing the
whole story of the martian prime
minister
it's hard to say what's going to happen
next to them technically they should end
up being chased by the free navy but
beyond seeing them get those ships i
don't really know what the motivation
would be
and if there was a chase related to that
it would have to happen almost
immediately
so that's another question i'll throw
out to you guys and i think this is a
good place to wrap things up
let me know what you think in the
comments what do you think of the
changes they've made what do you think
it means for the overall story
as mentioned at the end of the season
i'll do another one of these where we
can do like a full speculation about how
season six will end and in the meantime
i'm really interested to hear what
you're
thinking please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon